tenemos este problema el perímetro de
una cerca rectangular mide 0.72
kilómetros la longitud del largo del
área cercada es 160 metros 160 metros
cuál es su ancho ok la primera cosa que
yo observo y quizás tú también ya te
diste cuenta de eso es que nos dan
kilómetros y nos dan metros es decir nos
dan unidades mezcladas así que
convendría pasar todo a un mismo tipo de
unidades como nos dan el largo en metros
y nos piden el ancho voy a suponer que
el ancho también nos lo piden en metros
así que voy a empezar pasando todo a
metros déjame empezar con el perímetro
que le voy a poner pe y que nos dicen
que es de 0.72 kilómetros entonces
queremos pasar este este perímetro a
metros cuántos metros hay en un
kilómetro pues hay mil metros entonces
hay que multiplicar esto por mil metros
por mil metros y dividir entre un
kilómetro entre un kilómetro
y bueno me puedes preguntar cómo sabes
que hay que multiplicar por mil y no
dividir entre mil y hay dos formas de
pensarlo una vez que un kilómetro es una
unidad mucho más grande que un metro un
kilómetro tiene varios metros de hecho
tiene mil verdad entonces si tenemos
cierta cantidad de kilómetros deberíamos
de tener más metros porque son más cosas
chiquitas vale bueno esta es una forma
de pensarlo otra forma de pensarlo es
haciendo un análisis dimensional
queremos que los kilómetros se cancelen
con kilómetros y que las unidades nos
queden metros por eso ponemos kilómetros
en el denominador y metros en el
numerador vale entonces aquí kilómetros
se cancela con kilómetros y haciendo la
operación tenemos que hacer mil por 0.72
eso eso consiste en recorrer este punto
decimal tres lugares uno dos tres cada
que multiplicamos por 10 se recorre una
verdad entonces poniendo un cero
auxiliar ahí nos queda que el perímetro
es 720 metros muy bien ya tenemos el
perímetro
ahora tenemos que recordar que es el
perímetro para que podamos determinar el
ancho así que déjame dibujar aquí un
rectángulo
a ver si me queda más o menos bonito ahí
va el rectángulo nada más falta un lado
ahí está que es el perímetro pues el
perímetro consiste en sumar la longitud
de todo lo que está alrededor y aquí en
los rectángulos tenemos dos tipos de
longitud es el que nos dan que es el
largo y el largo que nos dicen que es de
160 metros 160 metros y el que tenemos
que determinar que es el ancho déjame
llamarle a entonces si éste mide l es
también mide l y éste también mi idea y
el perímetro es sumar estas cuatro
cantidades es decir el perímetro el
perímetro lo podemos poner como a más el
más a más
l pero ya tenemos información acerca de
algunas de estas letras
sabemos que el perímetro el perímetro es
720 metros lo calculamos aquí arriba
entonces
720 metros es igual a a qué tenemos que
determinar más 160 metros que es el más
a más 160 metros y hay varias formas de
encontrar el valor de a partir de aquí
una podría ser la siguiente observa que
el perímetro es más l más a más l
así que si nada más sumamos a más l
tendríamos la mitad del perímetro
tenemos una de cada una de las letras
entonces déjame ponerlo aquí abajo
tenemos que el perímetro o más bien
tenemos que ama se lo voy a poner así a
más
l que es 160 metros 160 metros es igual
a la mitad del perímetro el perímetro es
720 metros entonces la mitad sería 360
metros
y ahora tenemos que preguntarnos cuál
debe de ser el valor de a para que a más
160 nos de 360 esta es una forma de
hacerlo mentalmente y obtenemos
obtenemos que a es igual a 200 metros
pero si quieres ser un poquito más
formal teniendo esta igualdad podemos
restar 160 metros de ambos lados en 260
menos 160 y ver qué nos queda aquí
restando se cancelan estos dos nos queda
que a es igual a 360 menos 160 otra vez
nos queda 200 metros vale entonces
tenemos aquí una forma de obtener el
valor de a éste de aquí sería el ancho
en metros pero también podemos continuar
por este camino por este camino como le
haríamos pues saber vamos a continuar
con esta con esta cadena de igualdades
tenemos que 720 metros es igual a 120
metros 160 metros más 160 metros es 320
metros a más a es 2a
sumar una cosa consigo mismo es consigo
misma es dos veces la cosa entonces
tenemos que 720 metros es igual a 320
metros más 2 y aquí podemos restar 320
en 20 metros de ambos lados o bien
pensar cuánto tiene que ser 2a para que
nos queden 720 de cualquier forma nos
queda que 400 400 metros es igual a 2
y finalmente aquí podemos pues pensar en
que a debe de ser 200 metros o bien para
hacerlo un poco más formal dividir entre
2 a ambos lados de esta de esta igualdad
por un medio por un medio aquí se
cancela el 2 aquí también nos queda 400
entre dos que es 200 y por lo tanto
también llegamos a que a es igual a 200
metros